yeah if you're new here uh welcome
I know a lot of people will find me on
YouTube and then carry over to Twitch
but twitch is where I do all the live
streaming at some point I am considering
doing a live stream on YouTube
and or Instagram and or tick tock
um just to try and broaden the reach
reach different audiences
ooh who's this
okay
um I almost played D4 for muscle memory
but I'm in the stick with English
and we have E6 so this is what I play as
black now we transpose into qgd
uh Bishop B4 yeah this is very trendy
trying to remember the line you know
I know there's some like G5
I think 92 wait not not in this position
is each word first
and then 92.
yeah there's like takes takes takes
takes
my opponent is probably going to be more
prepared than me
remember
um Ray Robson showing me the sign
a few months ago
we were traveling for this Abu Dhabi
tournament and he was uh like casually
brought this up as like an interesting
trendy variation
um so this is all I know
Knight G7 doesn't really work
I assume just Bishop D3 looks solid
some funny idea Bishop F5 and Knight G7
I think the why is there a bug like a
small gnat in my face
um as I saying Knight F4 looks like a
natural Square for the night
have to be careful because Queen being
tied down
I mean queen F3 maybe like
and the King side looks very weak for
black I assume black wants to Queen side
castle at some point
but development is a little bit slow
so along that F6
also allowing Rook H4
my ruggage for take taking off one
yeah I mean this looks good for white
unless I'm like misjudging something or
missing something
and lacking went back the pawn
but in the very end I'm having threats
of Knight G7 and Knight F6 to win The
Rook
castling won't really help lack
castling is a
one way to end the pain of relax
so Rook C1 looks good
now yeah the Queen's side down to both
pieces
Brooks tied down so I have to untangle
somehow
a rook is rook's kind of tied down
like Queen D2 Rook C3
there's G4 there's Bishop E2 maybe
bishop E2
it's a bit passive though
there's E4 as well
to be Queen D2 Rook C3
this bug this bug is like
it just crosses my line of vision so
many times hard to get rid of so Rook C3
and queen B2
E4 is on the horizon
so unpinning The Rook Queen V6 I have
Rook B3
might be threatening taking maybe not
yet though
Queen's still tied down to the Rook this
might be a threat
A3 Queen C7 maybe F4 F5 later
still looks Pleasant
wait this is just winning
I saw this this I'm realizing I'm
winning B7 in the end
the queen has no other squares
a king C8 still goes on or King D6 wow
I have this move
oh no my rook and then checkmate
let's not get too excited
looks really good though
yeah there's Knight D7 oh no my Rook
someone call an ambulance
so Knight G7 E4
and then oh no my knight and oh no my
Rook
King is really safe on that fun
wait where's it made in the end
E4
I should have calculated this I was just
looking at this line Rook H4 here here
he can goes to C5 and The Rook actually
defends
I hope I don't mess this up
wait there's King E7
someone actually call an ambulance
but maybe not for me
wait a minute
this is really bad
I have this and
take
it should still be okay I think
oh no
oh it's so bad
wait the phone's about to lose on time
though
oh no wait
wow what's happening
G4
or take
in G4 first
foreign
[Music]
okay
oh wow
I completely forgot about King E7 I
thought it was being so clever
I was such a smooth game up until
actually blundering my Rook
oh because I just assumed The Rook still
cuts off a king
twitch
although that game wasn't the most
calming at least towards the end
I was so calm out of the opening
yeah I mean
I guess I had to be a little bit more
alert and probably a different move a
cure
like G7
[Music]
I got too excited though
what to do